okay four people joining this live
stream we are a bit late here we are
talking about D experimental izing
functions in most language this is the
part of a long series meetings also
today we have a lot of livestream
meetings about different things and but
um we're gonna start with us so the
question is should we be committing to
these functions for ever and we are
looking at these um okay for web image
search I've already said I would like to
change the default yes so we need
wishing you back plate and update the
documentation but we already have that
working locally okay um what about um is
there a second argument
um and should we allow something that
just says web image search of tiger
comma 10 to get 10 Tigers as an illusion
of the of the syntax so we're currently
using that site and for dirt and that's
um their argument because the second one
is the element you once you get right no
I understand that but one thing that is
a syntax allusion we sometimes make is
some
the
um is to simply put a number in that
second argument I'm not sure how
important that is all right we can leave
that out for now okay I think this
design is okay I think it doesn't need
to be experimental the only concern
[Music]
yeah okay and we have our various
mechanisms for other people's terms of
use and for service credit to flow
through that's that's all what is really
is that correct yeah and also we're
adding since we are removing this
default data set returning the
thumbnails we're adding a new element it
is called data set that returns what
it's returning right now good okay okay
and you should leave the thumbnails
thing as the explicit version of what
automatic is doing okay I don't see a
problem with the experimental izing that
web search I think I feel the same way
about um although I don't know how much
people I mean how much
you know a separate issue is we have
some dependency ice tunnel vendors for
these things at this time um that will
probably continue for for web search it
might not continue for web image search
well
and let me look at what else you're
proposing here
yeah what Wikipedia search has the
problem that it isn't following the
design pattern of the other search
functions is it right and what was do we
have a proposed design to fix that or
not not right now
we never work a lot on designing these
that our attention was more focused and
we'll keep a today de that's been
working fine for the last I don't know
three or a year right okay but but in
the search thing the there was an
attempt to make the text search and
Wikipedia search and I think several
other search and web search right you
know what you know what hold on a second
hold on hold on just a moment I don't
understand how we can do experimental
eyes these you know given the text
search we still don't have a clear
pattern for
let's see what I mean we don't have a
clear pattern um for what the you know
tagging of different types is like what
we have in Wikipedia search where
there's you know title etc etc etc right
where we want to talk about returning a
search result object but I don't know
what happened with it oh yeah you know
what let's not be experimental eyes
these things sorry
there's also male search and resource
search so maybe at some point you have
to look at all this we have been looking
at all of them we had a series of
meetings to look at all of them and
somehow died off but those need to be
reinitiated in word search
what word what word search is oh it's an
option okay um okay questions my live
stream when deciding on special features
to be taken to account usage statistics
well statistics about usage usually we
for privacy reasons don't know anything
about what people are specifically doing
with functions the only thing we can
know is when they're calling an external
API and we're with we're counting how
many calls they make we wish we did know
more actually we were for some of our
code assistance stuff we'd love to have
and we may end up with some kind of data
donor program where people are giving us
um
opting into giving us more data about
what they're actually doing um because
we would like to know statistics about
people particularly as they're typing
code and making mistakes we'd like to
know what what mistakes they're making
and not making um question is is whether
image search free well we wish it was I
mean it's using an external image search
API
maybe one day we will have done our own
web crawls and gotten our own images but
for the time being we are relying on an
external on an external provider
um so sadly it's not there's not - right
there's two external providers right -
yes yeah yes and I don't think we've
actually investigated having an image
only web search provider and perhaps we
could do that I'm not sure if there's
some because there are a number of
services that just do a research I don't
know what their quality level is um I
think that the web
research is in many ways for many of the
uses people want but just get me a bunch
of sample pictures of tigers and things
is much less demanding than web search
in terms of ranking and so it's much
more realistic that one can do a simpler
job and still be very useful well and
something we are thinking about um ah
yeah Bryan is asking how a web search be
refined you absolutely restricting to
particular sites file types etc um the
yeah I mean we can pass through to our
to those api's both for things that
consumers get to pass through and I
think there may be some other options
that are available in the api's that are
not not readily available to consumers
or a kind of message syntax but we can
already feel they're those things who
have options for site and file type do
we have the option so do we only have
the messer thing in the format of the
external service but there also some
normalized things that we support right
but this is the search query string
version I mean this is again again we
have got to go and look at all these
such things together because they have
different behavior with respect to
search query string etc because that's
that's dealing with you know some things
have wildcards some things don't some
things take you know use quotes in
certain ways etc um all right I think
that's all we can get to fer okay so
let's request
well I don't think the tasks framework
is going to stay experimental I see no
reason it should
does anybody I think we're we're we've
got that in in this collection does
anybody here wants to talk about the
tasks framework I mean to me the tasks
framework seems like it's working fine
anybody want to comment on that
reservations for tasks I tend to
explicitly say anything about it but if
it is well let's get that on another day
experimental ization meeting but let's
remember that when we are when we figure
out the answer to that it will affect
service submit service request Roger I
think you can you can yeah I can rush
this is a mess since the whole service
credits framework is changing we
definitely don't want to do experimental
eyes that all right next item
you
you
we're window object so I haven't used
these enough to be sure about this but
I'll note I think you're here and you
have been using these right web execute
and so on yeah I think I think that's
have you been able to I think so yeah
and so if I if I looked at tests you've
written the code for those tests is
civilized
what does civilized mean there yeah
what's that I mean it doesn't have a lot
of weird idioms in it um I wanted to say
you want to start a session no I don't
but I I want to say something like come
[Music]
let's got to be a website at viscom
we're about to find out what it is
what was that pink box that I saw there
well great okay shell dot-com okay this
could be could be very dangerous just
going for all these random calm okay oh
yeah about that of course yeah that's a
fine Dutch company there you go or
something um okay so that that worked
fine so my question about web execute is
really about all of the kind of weird
commands that are inside web execute I
mean I think that will expand over time
it may change over time but it's not a
you know it's let it always grandfather
both to your claim yeah I mean you know
like who knows like ten years from now
what's gonna happen with web browsers
and if things you know like change
significantly but for now I think this
is a reasonable set of things to support
so I mean your basic point is web
browsers I mean there's an analogy here
perhaps I mean to let's look at things
that we supported thirty years ago that
relate to external stuff and whether
we're upset by them I mean we certainly
had things for print
drivers which are long-lost nouns but it
didn't do us any harm to have them there
and they just quietly retire I'm not
sure they were built-in functions that
had if we may have had one built-in
function for that you know I just don't
know what's gonna happen with you know
web browsers ten or fifteen years from
now so yeah well I know but except that
we can have an expectation based on I
mean the issue is if web browsers go
away for example then but you know the
question is this structure of having you
know essentially key value pairs as a
way to execute things it's kind of messy
it's not really beautiful it reminds me
of what we need to do for the virtual
machines that we're building which
supposedly you know I don't know I tell
like Christian was here when am I
finally gonna see the etherion virtual
machine code on your case reviewing that
then should ask for a meeting again soon
I've been told that for like three or
four months if not six months my
question is you know if we look at those
virtual machines right that's another
example of a virtual machine right it is
the design that we are using for web
execute which is essentially like a
virtual machine um
compatible with the other things we plan
for virtual machines
did you understand my question I
understand the question but I've not
seen those other virtual machine sir I
don't I can't comment on that I mean the
reason we're doing using strings and
rules here is because you know we we
don't want to have like 20 or 25
functions you know at top level function
so that that was the reason you know
these these actions were made
you know like strings with with then you
know elements that they use I mean in
experimental in the lower level code
they're all functions right there's a
locate elements function so we should
end it I mean look web image seems to me
pretty harmless it's very similar to you
know current screen image and so on I
think it is pretty harmless let's I mean
we said the experiment slice because we
don't you know particularly plan to work
on this for the next couple of years I
mean is it this is you know maintenance
modes but that's not an argument to do
that I mean the fact is you know these
are things which are I mean ultimately
it's of you if you want to do another
redesign of it that's fine but you know
we're not gonna do it anytime soon
you're absolutely correct I mean unless
the usage of it climbs dramatically we
find horrible problems with the current
design or but you know I think it is
what we don't want to do is you know
yeah um and I think people are using it
I don't think there's major complaints
about you know I understand I understand
that but I there's no reason that the
cost to leaving something experimental
is not particularly high I mean it's
going to become higher when we start
certifying user api's and refusing to do
that when things are experimental then
our people are going to be more
concerned about whether things are
experimental or not and and there may
have to be some complicated negotiation
about user api's
with that make use of experimental
functions and where would we will agree
to certify them and you know and and
guarantee that they'll stay compatible
on such like
um but I think what an earth is this
this is what is this this is the Python
what is that why is this considered
experimental well it is experimental and
we wanted to stay experimental until
that's completely you know done done and
dusted and I wouldn't say that's
completely a finished project or even
you know finished design why because of
sandboxing or what well much because of
sandbox and that's the implementation
issue I think the design I mean you
skipped over all the external thyroid
functions a minute ago when you scroll
down to this to the web execute stuff
would we think that dad's stop although
it works fine probably might need a
little bit of redesign especially things
like sternal function external object
we're still plan to add more functions
which may affect the design and I think
at some point you know like we have
enough languages where we say okay you
know this this is a good design you know
we don't expect you know major surprises
but I don't think we have quite enough
language I mean your issue for example
external function could work for
languages like like C and so on um and
which clearly external evaluate is not
going to work for at least not in any
obvious way
I mean look to me the more obvious thing
that we need to do here is to assess
because the sooner we make if we are
going to need to change some design of
external evaluate the sooner we do that
the better yeah I think quite widely
used and so what what is it exactly that
you think you want to change well that's
one issue is I mean external function
external object both are not supported
by a lot of languages it's not clear if
they're designed correctly and it's
especially it's not clear how invention
will integrate external evaluate with
scaling for example
and in yeah I think until we've seen our
Lincoln J link how they integrate with
external evaluate it's gonna be hard to
get the designs or these things right no
I think external value external object
these are all kind of complicated yes
alright so we thought we just treat the
whole suite and leave it as experimental
instead of trying to pick and choose a
few functions that we can do
experimental eyes okay
what is this why is SH authentication
why is that something that is still
deeply experimental what is there that
needs to be done here can somebody speak
to that you know thinking who put it in
who made this statement here well we
don't know so Raj this needs to come you
need to how about you you get B signed
please it's a so rash is out today okay
well so in future can we make sure that
these statements get signed so we don't
have a nobody knows who wrote this
situation yeah okay
okay let's go on let's see whether
there's anything that we can quickly do
because there's clearly a lot of stuff
here that's a whole complicated story
synthetic geometry oops
geometry was a guide page okay angle
bisector simply evaluates and gives a
primitive correct yes
you know I really wish people wouldn't
use these microscopic weird script
characters and documentation but that's
a that's just a pet peeve
okay so let's see what other things here
these are all of the UM is Roger in this
meeting does he have comments on these
he is not in this meeting okay I don't
understand why midpoint returns this
value here oh I see midpoint I get it
midpoint of just the naked coordinates
returns naked coordinates how does that
work for angle bisector if you feed it
in here you're giving naked coordinates
yet you're getting out a line object how
can that be consistent I mean the angle
bisector there's nothing else we can
really return besides an infinite line
whereas for midpoint if the user puts in
the naked coordinates they get out of
naked coordinates but if they put in so
you broke up we couldn't hear you things
a point what we know for midpoint you're
getting out if you put in points you get
out points but for angle bisectors you
put in naked coordinates you're getting
out your eyes right that's odd it's
really the only choice
why why isn't it a unit factor or
something
you
we needed to represent the angle
bisector energy hood work
it's yeah inside a geometric scene we
it's it got it jives better with the
inside geometric scene where we can you
know we actually you know draw into that
lines but we don't support vectors
inside of geometric scene okay this is
not going to fly yet by the way I'm
noticing on our live stream um all kinds
of comments here um the the other nice
thing about infinite line is it doesn't
matter which way the angles oriented I
understand I'm not buying this
completely I mean I'm buying it if that
if if you feed into angle bisector a
thing that is a wrapped symbolics
geometric object then getting infinite
line out to make sense if you feed in
something which is just a bunch of naked
coordinates it is much less obvious to
me that that makes sense and for your
purposes in geometric scene you only
care about the case where you're feeding
in properly wrapped symbolic objects
alright sir my internet connection
connect then then we have to do this a
different time um the okay let me just
look ahead here and see whether there
are other things here which are more
obvious
you
you
yeah these can be the experimentalist
these are really
you
you
well unless somebody is what is being
complained here about here I mean the
question of what it is using internally
what does it even say what it does there
doesn't wait where did this come from
Vienna that's my own comment we are
using Emacs files for various stuff this
tour but when you given the Memex file
will do do with that it's look not clear
why they it's encrypted or something
else what are you talking about I mean
the encrypt file is using encryption
what it is doing on the how it is
representing the underlying expression I
would have expected it to use bindings
binary serialize for the underlying
expression yes I'm talking about how it
stores the Critias file stores it where
in MX file which is a generic container
wait wait wait wait wait it's not an MX
file it I don't understand if I say
encrypt file it is ok we cannot do
experimental eyes this this is the total
mess then that doesn't make any sense
because you there are max files oh you
used away with ok this meeting is not
going well ok and and we're going to
have to rap because we've got another
another thing another live stream about
um it's about image and video formats
coming up in just a few minutes here um
but I would like to ok this is not OK
look these things the good news is these
were experimental have we agreed to the
experimental eyes anything in this
meeting
okay nobody even knows so I think the
answer is I think we said web image
could be the experimental eyes but let's
not do that because we're doing this too
and to rush it away so before we put web
image search and web search back into
the experiments Association meetings
maybe we can have a search meeting to
talk about okay okay yeah this is a
total mess the stuff here this is
there's no way with the experimental
icing this yet um and um okay some
comments to people on the live stream
Brian wants to know does web execute
default HTTP or HTTP how does one
specify the default I'll try to answer
that offline I'm looking at the code
right now so it's bad that you have to
look at the code to answer that so we
obviously need yeah I mean most people
you know I would recommend you
specifying it yourself as a user so you
know if you want to use HTTP you you
specify it like that if you want to use
HTTP you specified like that but and I
don't think it's a default in yeah sure
sure so it's yes and it's also sometimes
even if you put in HTTP it is not
necessarily HTTP because for example
Google will redirect you to a strength
yes
but yeah but there is a default where
you use and I'm trying to look at their
standard now from Google and Firefox is
HTTP Lib coal which is another standard
I agree the default should be HTTPS yes
yes okay thank you I still evaluate
children's support to c-sharp that says
Brian how
how can it it's not an interpretable
language is it I mean it could external
function could support c-sharp I think
there's a raffle for c-sharp I say boy
that's right even if there isn't
external function yeah I cell function
is a different thing um Ali is saying
remove functions don't leave them
hanging I'll keep working on them and
remove them completely I don't think
people would like that
you know this is one of the challenges
it's it's a I'm gonna expound on this
just for a minute for everybody's sake I
mean you know in areas that are not well
developed like supporting I don't know
fancy features of controlling web
browsers we can say well we're just not
going to do it we can say we'll have
something in the function repository
maybe now I mean that's a new option for
us or we can have something that we're
pretty sure is going to be stable but
it's not going to be as stable as
something like nested list or something
where it'll never change um and so it's
that's what we've invented this
experimental mechanism for now it is
possible that as we have more
experimental functions that we should
have shades of experimental ization or
that we should have commentary in the
documentation about why something is
experimental um but you know it is
unfortunately finishing a design can be
a lot of work it can involve stuff we
simply don't know that depends on how
the world develops or how you know or
how people choose to use things things
we can't foresee and that's you know
that's why we need this experimental
stuff um but you know I consider it a a
a good solution to an ugly problem of
how do we live over functionality
you know years earlier than it could be
incredibly polished and the question of
whether it is the right prioritization
once we have delivered a preliminary
version of something as an experimental
form to what keep working on that thing
as opposed to other things I tend to
think that it's better to put some of
these things out there and see what
happens and see how people use them see
whether they find them useful see
whether there are awkward corners that
they keep on running into I mean like
for example the web image research you
know thumbnails being the default I
wouldn't have necessarily said that on
day one I only say that because I've
used it hundreds of times or more and I
pretty much always use that option
um the yes alley on a live stream is
saying use them we'd love to have
polished finished functions believe me
we are doing our best to make that the
case but it is challenging when the
world changes and when things when we're
sort of building on foundation of sand
because we're trying to connect to
something externally in the world and
it's a completely different story when
we've got purely internal functions like
angle bisector we should be able to nail
how that works because that's only under
our control you know it's something like
external evaluate or web execute it's a
little bit of a different story um
however an experimental function sounder
asks that have been killed afterwards
the answer is yes although I'm not sure
I can quote we definitely changed things
and experimental functions we've yes
we've had some which have changed there
which have changed name or bin and being
just completely killed it is not a
common phenomenon
okay so Ali is suggesting that there's a
different colour um that um it's used
when one uses an experimental function
and that is something we might consider
I just don't know you know I you know
that the problem is it's very
personality dependent for people I mean
there are people who will use you know
we see this in encode bases emotion
language code bases that people who'll
use things which we just tell them
that's you know
you're using something that is a
completely undocumented behavior that's
a bad idea and people will say but it
works and and therefore they'll use it I
think that there's kind of a lint like a
process that needs to go on of saying
look you know and maybe maybe the right
answer to this is when we introduce our
new level of code assistants that one of
the things and this is something we
should be making a note of but something
that can be returned as part of that
code assistance is information on what
functions that you are using or
experimental I think that's the you know
that's more of a pick off the lint
detail question I think rather than
something that's in your face because I
think that typically these functions you
know we don't make functions
experimental you know lightly they're
made that way because that's the only
way we could get functionality in there
this year rather than several years from
from now um-um Brian is saying he's
likes the idea of documenting weii
functional experimental I like that too
and I think it will be worth putting in
there you know that it's experimental I
mean so what would be say for example
for some of these you know web execute
we could write the small essay about why
web execute is mental that basically
explains that we we're not sure that
this mechanism for taking um you know
that this will agree with our general
virtual machine mechanism and so on
might alert whether other people in this
meeting it's probably the wrong meeting
to really go through the discussion of
documenting the the reasons for
experimental for the something being
experimental but it does anybody have a
quick reaction to that no all right
listen
we should go so one long comments here
let's see there's questions here about
um support for Julia I believe that's
coming in to our point one card can you
confirm that yeah I'm coming in twelve
point one I replied okay ready um okay
Brian is suggesting that the
experimental and supportive function
should be five as part of the publishing
process if you if you cloud publish an
API for example yeah I think that that
is that should be part of the whole code
assistance story
um the okay and Ali is suggesting a
checkbox in preferences that enables
highlighting experimental functions
that's an interesting idea
I'm not sure hopefully we'd at least
have one user of that I think that's an
interesting idea and maybe that could be
put who is taking notes here okay so
that's something for the probably the
code assistants meeting just um even is
mentioning that if we support all these
things like Python and notebooks we
should have syntax coloring we are we
are well aware of this issue is being
worked on we think we have a solution we
just need to not have to we need to have
something which is a general solution
rather than a a specific solution and we
think we have one and it's possible that
it will make it into 12 one um all right
so listen for those who are into live
streams we are about to do another one
we will be taking about a five minute
break and then we will be doing image
video and input export features for 12.1
so stay tuned and we probably need to
can we bring up in the product release
meeting next week the whole question of
what's happening with us to experimental
ization process and it would have been
good if Raj was here hopefully he'll be
there for that okay yeah okay see y'all
soon